>> Bret: CATHERINE, THANK
YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Bret: A PUBLISHED REPORT
IS IDENTIFYING JARED KUSHNER
AS ONE MORE THAN TWO DOZEN
OFFICIALS WHOSE SECURITY
CLEARANCE DENIALS WERE
OVERRULED BY A SENIOR
OFFICIAL.
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTING KUSHNER'S INITIAL
APPLICATION WAS DENIED OVER
CONCERNS ABOUT FOREIGN
INFLUENCE, PRIVATE BUSINESS
INTEREST AND PERSONAL
CONDUCT.
KUSHNER IS MARRIED, OF
COURSE, TO IVANKA TRUMP.
MONDAY, KUSHNER TOLD LAURA
INGRAHAM HE IS NOT A RISK TO
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> I CAN'T COMMENT FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE'S PROCESS, BUT
WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS THAT I
HAVE BEEN HERE I HAVE BEEN
ACCUSED OF ALL DIFFERENT
TYPES OF THE THINGS AND ALL
THOSE THINGS HAVE TURNED OUT
TO BE FALSE.
>> Bret: HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE HAS VOTED TO ISSUE